Brian McKnight in studio with us 16
Grammy nominations but you never won
never won not that it matters no it does
matter Brian it matters for the
perception of the public not to say that
wouldn't want one of my brothers got 10
he's got 10 grand does he rub it in that
he's got to know because when he comes
in my house he sees 60 million albums
you scoreboard your brother would you
rather have one um
Aska Grammy nomination and one win or 16
nominations and no wins obviously you'd
want to win but to me you you have to
win on other levels to not have to worry
about whether you win what's your answer
Brian you want 16 nominations yeah I do
over the one win yeah you got one would
you rather be a 1 you don't know there's
when people introduce you you want the
perception to be that he's a Grammy
winner because to the public winning a
Grammy means that you're great which it
does but not having one doesn't make you
not great and I'd use the emphasis of
double- just a parentheses and evening
with Brian McKnight a live collection
featuring Brian's biggest hits as well
as the new hit single everything which
he'll be playing for is here in a moment
best singer in the NBA past or present
is Walter McCarty really yeah former
Kentucky for yeah yeah Walter and I we
go back and forth on Twitter all the
time he's I heard him sing an anthem one
time I was like hey that guy can sing
what about Shaq Shaq some rapper rappers
Ratheon he's singing okay the difference
between like are they're good singing
rapper or is it just rapping singing is
different I think Drake is a guy that
can rap and can sing you know he's a
better rapper than he's a singer but
he's getting better but the very few
guys that actually I mean with with
auto-tune anybody can sing I mean I'd
and I could take you in the studio
whether you can sing or not you can make
a huge hit because of the technology
that we have
I could sound like Adele no I could not
but
you could sound good a better basketball
player Drake or Justin Bieber I haven't
seen Drake play I've seen Justin shoot
and Justin has shot the ball before
Drake wants to play so badly he's in the
front row I saw him in the layup line in
the Kentucky thing and I was I wasn't
that's not the guy but Brian that's
where somebody says to Drake well in in
his defense how many people get to go
through Kentucky's layup line
very few only the guys that play at
Kentucky I think you've recruited by
Kentucky anybody in the room get
recruited by Kentucky No so if the hippy
calls and wants me to go through the
layup line I go through now I would make
every layer I shot he did not look good
he did not look good when you met Kobe
how old was Kobe when you did the video
with Coco B I think was in his it was
the summer after his rookie season and
you approach him and say you want to be
in my video you know he was actually
making a record here in New York with
some producers that I was working and
he's saying he's a rapper so again he
could rap he wasn't singing
but he wasn't bad but I think that he
realized that that wasn't the route he
needed to go if he was gonna be
considered a serious basketball player I
don't think it would have mattered
because we saw what he became but at
that time he didn't have the greatest
rookie season no no no he didn't you
know and I think that's what hurt his
points-per-game average over over time
but what he became nobody ever
remembered that he was rapping who do
you get mistaken for I get mistaken for
LeBron so then our small or I mean 6-8
to 50 of yeah 6 5 192 are you friends
with him acquaintances yeah I met LeBron
when he was in high school my son was
that Jordan camp for several years and
and he came up the summer before his
senior year in high school so I met him
then we we've I don't say I'm friends
with people we know each other I suppose
in passing Steph Curry Steph Curry I've
met a couple of times he's he's kind of
guy I don't I just want to stand and
watch him do what he does I don't want
to hang out with people I just I
love guys who are great at something and
watching them do something that they're
really great at which is what we'll do
now segue Brian's gonna sing his hit
single everything you're ready to go
ready to go all right fire away Brian
McKnight beautiful beautiful face
beautiful sky beautiful beautiful
beautiful tell me how'd you get such a
beautiful beautiful spirit beautiful
voice every time I hear it beautiful
mouth I can't be reused every time you
let me kiss you baby
inside
baby
my everything
strengthening your they can do anything
to watch her you can never be
baby
baby
my everything
my everything
thank you so great to sing that in a
room full of like seven guys I'm like oh
no I look over there but I thought you
were singing it to me yeah okay now your
girlfriend has to ask you the question
did you write that about her
so three years ago I'm in my dressing
room in Korea with my guitar and this
song came to me and I like wait how does
songs come to pee okay you know how you
have a playlist in your on your iPad or
on the phone you have a playlist of your
songs that you love so I have that but I
also have a playlist of songs in my head
that are constantly going around that
haven't been written yet and
occasionally during the day it'll just
hit me like oh because I have melodies
and chord changes going through my head
all day long and a lyric will present
itself you may say something like oh
that's an interesting idea and then boom
the words just start to flow so you'd be
sampling me yeah well I wouldn't tell
you
give me one do not about writing a song
in a room full of people are there
certain people you wouldn't want to sing
with because the voice might be a little
too much for you no I've been working on
this not that with a minute it goes I
just wouldn't an evening with Brian
McKnight live collection featuring
Brian's biggest hits as well as the song
he just before everything coming out CD
DVD blu-ray
that'll be Friday music wherever it's
sold bright thank you for coming in Dan
Patrick show we
on audience